thank you all for coming to auditions  for the next starting quarterback of the  Cleveland Browns yeah and remember the  health benefits are awful so just a  break a leg everyone hi I'm Tim Tebow  Jesus Christ what about him that's my  dude what'd you say your name was again  my name is Ed Jimmy Garoppolo I know  it's you Tom I hate your guts roger  goodell you know it's all about getting  another one for the lame-o Brian Browns  in the house hold up this is Eva Herstal  for Space Jam to a screwed  tell them the Baltimore again  [Music]  man where's our food should be here any  minute Calvin hey I read a rumor beast  modes leaving the retirement home  yeah he's leaving but just to go get  skittles hey Peyton papa no oh awkward